the dog just went into i'm sorry this is the worst i'm gonna like i'm gonna get a new co-host price you've gone so available i'm just saying welcome to adsp the podcast episode 94, recorded on August 15th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we continue with part three of our four-part interview with Kate Gregory, where we talk about the future of CPP North and her most recently released Pluralsight courses. My elderflower cordial situation, which is a perfectly ordinary drink in the UK. And every time I go, I bring back like four or five bottles wrapped up in my suitcase.
dog just went into i'm sorry this is the worst i'm gonna like i'm gonna get a new co-host price you've gone so available i'm just saying 欢迎收听 adsp 播客第 94 期，录制于 2022 年 8 月 15 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天与我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，我们继续进行对凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）四部分访谈的第三部分，在这一期中，我们讨论了 CPP North 的未来以及她最近发布的 Pluralsight 课程。我的接骨木花露（elderflower cordial）情况，这在英国是一种非常普通的饮料。每次我去，我都会在行李箱里裹上四五瓶带回来。
Like some people might bring back scotch if you're going to Scotland. Bryce, maybe you're going to bring back a lot of scotch, but I would just, it'd be elderflower cordial coming home with me. I am traveling pretty light to Scotland. It's just going to be a carry-on bag. So I think nothing's going to be coming home with me i am i am traveling pretty light to scotland it's just gonna be a carry-on bag so i think uh nothing nothing's gonna be coming back with me my my favorite thing this is gonna i mean i'm gonna get flamed for this but when i went to ireland for the second time to visit my sister earlier this year don't bring up the fact that you think you're irish no no that's it not the point here i mean i am half irish um i just uh will not do the i i don't think actually on this podcast i have done an
就像如果你去苏格兰，有些人可能会带回苏格兰威士忌。布莱斯，也许你会带回很多苏格兰威士忌，但我只会，带回接骨木花露。我去苏格兰的行李挺轻的。只有一个随身行李包。所以我觉什么也不会带回我我我去苏格兰的行李挺轻的。只有一个随身行李包。所以我觉呃什么也不会带回我我最喜欢的东西这个要我要挨骂了但今年早些时候我第二次去爱尔兰看望我姐姐的时候别提起你觉得自己是爱尔兰人这事儿不不就是这不是重点我的意思是我是有一半爱尔兰血统呃我只是呃不会在这个播客里我没有做过
irish accent you've told the story correct i'm not going to i'm not going to because i would not let you publish an episode i mean in which you did the scottish the irish accent because you would be banned from returning to Ireland. I don't think that's true. I got a legal sister. I don't know what the opposite of a legal sister is, but she's my sister and she lives there. So I get to go. But the thing I was going to mention is that I discovered this protein bar called Fulfill.
爱尔兰口音你讲过这个故事对吧我不打算我不打算因为我不会让你发布一集节目里面你模仿了苏格兰爱尔兰口音因为你会被禁止再次入境爱尔兰。我觉得这不是真的。我有一个法律上的姐姐。我不知道法律上的姐姐的反义词是什么，但她是我姐姐，而且她住在那里。所以我可以去。但我要提到的是，我发现了一种叫做 Fulfill 的蛋白质棒。
And the mint flavor is the best protein bar I've ever had. So, I mean, Kate's got her black licorice Mentos and I think it was elderflower tea. Elderflower something, something. I have a fair cordial. Yeah. Yeah. And Bryce has got a secret hot chocolate. That's a little bit different than tea.
而且薄荷味的蛋白质棒是我吃过最好的。所以，凯特有她的甘草味曼妥思，我想还有接骨木花茶。接骨木花什么的。我有接骨木花露。对。布莱斯有一种秘密热巧克力。这和茶有点不同。
Or sorry, what is, I don't even, I heard elderflower and I think my brain just like attached because I've seen elderflower. What is cordial? It's a concentrated fruit flavored syrup. You add water to it. Then you drink it. And it's like, like you could think of it as like a lemonade concentrate or something. Like a Kool-Aid, a European Kool-Aid kind of thing. Yeah, but it's so the number one thing in England is Ribena,
或者抱歉，什么是，我甚至，我听到接骨木花，我觉得我的大脑就像是黏住了，因为我见过接骨木花。什么是糖浆（cordial）？这是一种浓缩的水果味糖浆。你往里面加水。然后你喝它。这就像，你可以把它想象成柠檬汁浓缩液之类的东西。就像酷爱饮料（Kool-Aid），一种欧洲酷爱饮料那样的东西。对，但在英国最主要的是 Ribena，
which is blackcurrant. You can get Ribena here. There's a lime thing, which you can get here. But the elderflower is made from the flowers of elder. I actually planted elders at my house so that I can. It's a long-term strategy. It's going to be another 10 years or so but eventually I can make my own elderflower cordial oh wow yeah that makes I never I've
那是黑加仑味的。你可以在这里买到 Ribena。还有酸橙味的，你也可以在这里买到。但接骨木花是由接骨木的花制成的。我实际上在我的房子周围种了接骨木，这样我就可以。这是一个长期战略。大概还要十年左右，但最终我可以自己做接骨木花露哦，哇，是的，这使得我从来没
always just heard elderflower together I never put together I mean well that's there's other flowers like sunflower that you don't say without the flower part so there's an actual plant there's elderflowers and there's elderberries right your was it your mother was a hamster and your father smelled of elderberries might be the way around so monty but no you can't do monty python oh my goodness i know monty python i just don't you know it's his butt a scratch see i've redeemed myself a little bit um i just haven't seen them all yeah so elder berries and elder flowers both come from elders. Yes. Which is a tree thing. Good to know. Good to know.
一直只听到接骨木花连在一起，我从来没有把它们放在一起，我的意思是，还有向日葵这样的花，你不能不带“花”字来说，所以有一个真正的植物，有接骨木花和接骨木果，对吧？你的，是你的母亲是仓鼠，你父亲身上有接骨木果的味道？可能是反过来的，所以是蒙蒂（Monty），不，你不能演巨蟒剧团（Monty Python）哦天哪，我知道巨蟒剧团，我只是不，你知道，这只是擦伤，看，我稍微救赎了自己，呃，我只是没有看过全部，是的，所以接骨木果和接骨木花都来自接骨木。是的。这是一种树。很高兴知道。很高兴知道。
All right. So we've got, I think, roughly 15 minutes-ish left. Before we get to sort of talking about, because I think we should talk a little bit about your Pluralsight, because it's topical, Pluralsight course. Is there anything you want to say about future cpp north while we're on the topic of where we took a little digression to talk about sort of food and travel and whatnot i would definitely say plan on being there next summer and and there may be an opportunity uh we're discussing whether or not it's possible to let people have a super super super early bird while they're still remembering how great it was. Oh, wow.
好了。所以我们大概还有 15 分钟左右。在我们开始讨论之前，因为我觉得我们应该讨论一下你的 Pluralsight，因为这很合时宜，也就是 Pluralsight 课程。在我们讨论我们对食物、旅行等的稍微离题的讨论时，关于未来的 cpp North，你有什么想说的吗？我绝对会说，计划明年夏天去那里，而且可能会有一个机会呃，我们正在讨论是否有可能让人们在他们还记得它有多棒的时候拥有一个超级超级早鸟票。哦，哇。
But if you can't book now, you can at least talk to work about it now. An awful lot of people on Twitter were like, why was I not told this conference was happening? I would have gone. And it's like, well, come for 2023 then. We'll be very happy to have you. Yeah, it's hard with a first-time conference because I feel like the inner, I don't want to call it inner circle, but like the folks that are on C++ Twitter and that, you know, listen to C++ podcasts.
但如果你现在不能预订，你至少现在可以和工作单位谈谈。推特上有非常多的人说，为什么没有人告诉我这个会议正在举行？我会去的。然后就像，好吧，那就来参加 2023 年的吧。我们非常高兴欢迎你。是的，对于第一次举办的会议来说这很难，因为我觉得核心，我不想称之为核心圈子，但就像那些在 C++ Twitter 上并且，你知道，听 C++ 播客的人。
And because I think CppCast had an episode that, who went, was it Diana and Nat that both went on? I think Diana and Jason went on one and Nat and Mike went on another, but I may have the pairings mixed up. Okay. But you know what? When I asked in the keynote, how many of you, is this the first conference you've ever been to? And like a third of the room put their hand up. Yeah, that's true. So that was impressive.
因为我觉得 CppCast 有一集，是谁去的，是黛安娜（Diana）和纳特（Nat）都去了吗？我想黛安娜和杰森（Jason）去了一期，纳特和迈克（Mike）去了另一期，但我可能把配对记混了。好吧。但你知道吗？当我在主题演讲中问，你们有多少人，这是你们参加过的第一个会议吗？房间里大约有三分之一的人举起了手。是的，那是真的。所以这令人印象深刻。
We did get, you know, we did get some reach, but I think it's always in subsequent years after you've done it once and you've got people talking about it and trip reports going out and stuff. Well, we proved that we can do it, right? Like you put together a program that was a damn good conference program. And the speakers all had a good time. The attendees all had a good time. The venue is magical. You know, probably my favorite moment of the whole conference was Tuesday morning announcements when Mike said, lunch today is on the streets of Toronto. You know, just go out and find a place and spend $3 on a sandwich at St. Lawrence Market. The idea that people can eat.
我们确实，你知道，我们确实获得了一些影响力，但我认为总是在你举办过一次之后的随后的年份里，人们开始谈论它，旅行报告也随之发布等等。好吧，我们证明了我们可以做到，对吧？就像你策划了一个非常棒的会议日程。所有的演讲者都玩得很开心。与会者都玩得很开心。场地非常神奇。你知道，整个会议我最喜欢的时刻可能是周二早上的公告，当时迈克说，今天的午餐在多伦多的街头。你知道，出去找个地方，在圣劳伦斯市场花 3 美元买个三明治。人们可以吃饭的想法。
We spent more than $3. You spent a little bit more than $3. We didn't go to St. Lawrence Market. We went to Miku, which is very yummy but yes but that's kind of the deal right like you can you can get you can get a burger or some fries and gravy or whatever or you can you can have a very sophisticated meal and it's up to you and you're not in a in a conference center in the middle of nowhere where it's literally an hour walk just out through the parking lot uh i i was in i was in orlando in june or july because that's when you want to go to
我们花了不止 3 美元。你多花了一点钱。我们没有去圣劳伦斯市场。我们去了 Miku，非常美味，但是是的，但这就是这笔交易，对吧？就像你可以，你可以买个汉堡或一些薯条加肉汁之类的，或者你可以，你可以吃一顿非常精致的饭菜，这取决于你，你不在一个鸟不生蛋的会议中心里，从停车场走出去字面意思就要走一个小时呃我当时我在
orlando and the speaker hotel was right next to the conference center so they didn't run a bus and it took 25 minutes to walk through the hotel parking lot across the street and through the convention center parking lot where you finally collapsed in a puddle of sweat inside the first air conditioning you've been in. And I was like, you need a bus. I'm not doing this walk every day. It's so gross. But, you know, like that's the scale of a lot of conference centers. They're huge.
6 月或 7 月在奥兰多，因为那是你想去奥兰多的时间，演讲者酒店紧挨着会议中心，所以他们没有开班车，穿过酒店停车场、过马路、再穿过会展中心停车场花了 25 分钟，最后你终于在你体验过的第一个空调房里倒在了一滩汗水里。当时我想，你需要一辆班车。我不能每天都走这条路。太恶心了。但是，你知道，这就是许多会议中心的规模。它们太大了。
I think conferences that are in the city center are that that's the best option yeah it sometimes can be well sometimes it typically is a lot more expensive which is why certain conferences choose i won't say outskirty areas but just definitely it's not city center but the advantage but if you're um if you're at a conference location where the venue has you as a captive audience, they can charge whatever they want for food. Yeah. If people are saving $100 or $200 a night on the room rate, but they have no choice but to spend $100 a day on food. They're not gaining. Yeah. Yeah.
我认为位于市中心的会议室那是最好的选择，是的，有时它可能是，有时它通常要贵得多，这就是为什么某些会议选择，我不会说是偏远地区，但绝对不是市中心，但其优势在于，如果你身处一个场地将你作为俘虏观众的会议地点，他们可以对食物收取他们想要的任何费用。是的。如果人们每晚在房费上节省 100 或 200 美元，但他们别无选择，只能每天在食物上花费 100 美元。他们并没有赚到。是的。是的。
Or I remember I like to have a can or a bottle of Coke in the morning. I'll have one coffee and then I switch to Coca-Cola. And being in venues where they're like, no, I'm sorry, this is the Pepsi building. You can only have Pepsi. And also every ever like even even in expensive cities like Toronto and New York, there are budget options for lodging. Yeah. Yeah. I'm super happy with the with the locale and being able to walk from the train station. You know, I know Patrice took the train from Montreal. I took the GO train from the outskirts of town. You know, this carbon footprint thing is real and, you know, you don't necessarily have to fly. I think it's the future.
或者我记得我喜欢在早上喝一罐或一瓶可口可乐。我喝一杯咖啡，然后改喝可口可乐。身处那些场馆，他们会说，不，对不起，这是百事可乐大楼。你只能喝百事可乐。而且还有，甚至在多伦多和纽约这样昂贵的城市，也有预算实惠的住宿选择。是的。是的。我超级高兴能有这个地点，并且能够从火车站步行到达。你知道，我知道帕特里斯（Patrice）坐火车从蒙特利尔来。我坐 GO 火车从城镇边缘来。你知道，这个碳足迹的事情是真实的，而且，你知道，你不一定非得坐飞机。我认为这是未来。
Yeah, I can quote Titus Winters, who, as Bryce can reaffirm is a worldly individual with the man of tastes. And when I was chatting with him at the end of the conference, he wasn't even saying this just about CPP North, because I think he had been there before for a committee meeting in 2017 or so. And he said of all the places I visited Toronto, really is one of his favorites because of the diversity of food options like Toronto has great food in general, but also just a great diversity of different, you know, basically authentic cuisines from different parts of the world, because that is basically the people that make up Toronto
是的，我可以引用蒂图斯·温特斯（Titus Winters）的话，正如布莱斯可以再次证实的那样，他是一个有品位的世界主义者。当我在会议结束时与他聊天时，他甚至不是只针对 CPP North 说这句话，因为我想他以前在 2017 年左右为了委员会会议去过那里。他说在他去过的所有地方中，多伦多确实是他最喜欢的地方之一，因为食物选择的多样性，就像多伦多总的来说有很好的食物，而且还有来自世界不同地区的各种不同的，你知道的，基本上正宗的美食的大杂烩，因为那基本上是组成多伦多的人
is we've got different little micro communities and, you know, we all blend together, but like you can go to different parts of town and get, you know, really good sushi or really good Indian food or, you know, choose your cuisine, basically you can find it. And he said in his list of top restaurants, like a couple of them are in Toronto, which I guess I kind of take that for granted that, you know, I haven't lived in a
我们有不同的小微型社区，你知道，我们都融为一体，但你可以去城镇的不同地方，买到（你知道的）非常好的寿司、非常好的印度菜，或者，选择你的菜系，基本上你能找到它。他说在他的顶级餐厅名单中，其中几家在多伦多，我想我有点认为这是理所当然的，你知道，我没有在一个
ton of place. Definitely. It's got better food options than Sunnyvale, California. Oh, that's not true. Although it's a real shame that you can't get a decent bagel anywhere in Toronto. We did so well. We did so well. I mean, did we even settle the debate? I expected somebody to, like, kidnap me and sit me down, like, blindfolded and do a blind taste test of bagels while I was there. I was a little disappointed that didn't happen. I think there was Francis, who was a member of the
很多地方住过。绝对的。它的食物选择比加利福尼亚州森尼维尔要好。哦，那不是真的。虽然非常遗憾你在多伦多任何地方都买不到像样的贝果面包（bagel）。我们做得很好。我们做得很好。我的意思是，我们甚至解决这场辩论了吗？我以为会有人，比如，绑架我并让我坐下来，蒙上眼睛，在我在那里的时候做一个盲测贝果。我有点失望那没有发生。我想弗朗西斯（Francis）在那里，他是
C++ Montreal meetup, who came from Montreal, I believe, was there and I believe brought bagels on a Sunday maybe before the conference started. I can't remember exactly what happened. I flew in late on Sunday. I see.
C++ 蒙特利尔聚会的成员，据我所知他来自蒙特利尔，就在那里，而且我想在周日会议开始前可能带了贝果。我记不清具体发生了什么。我周日很晚才飞到。我明白了。
You missed the bagels. You missed the maple tarts. You're not getting the full conference experience, right? I will say this. Sorry. The dog is eating something. I don't know what the dog's eating. I will say this.
你错过了贝果。你错过了枫糖挞。你没有获得完整的会议体验，对吧？我要这么说。抱歉。狗在吃东西。我不知道狗在吃什么。我要这么说。
For next year, I will agree to a bagel blind test if somebody will arrange it. You bring some from New York. We'll get the Montreal folks to bring some. We'll get some bread donuts from Toronto, but we'll also get some real bagels from Toronto as well. We'll do some sort of bagel off. We'll figure out how to make it happen. I don't think you should be eating that oh he's not talking to us he's talking to the dog so you want to talk you want to talk about the course yeah um so this just got launched if i'm
对于明年，如果有人能安排的话，我会同意进行贝果盲测。你从纽约带一些来。我们会让蒙特利尔的人带一些来。我们会从多伦多买一些面包甜甜圈，但我们也会从多伦多买一些真正的贝果。我们会搞某种贝果大比拼。我们会想办法让它发生。我想你不应该吃那个哦，他不是在跟我们说话，他是在跟狗说话所以你想谈谈，你想谈谈课程吗？是的，呃，如果我
following the twitters correctly correct yes like the last business day of july or something i know i was so busy in July. I was so crazy busy in July. Really? What were you doing, Kate? What were you doing? I was like running this conference and practicing my keynote. And the way that I do the courses is first, I write everything 100% totally written.
推特没有关注错的话，这个刚刚发布对吧？是的，就像七月的最后一个工作日左右。我知道我在七月太忙了。我在七月忙得不可开交。真的吗？你在做什么，凯特？你在做什么？我当时在筹备这个会议并练习我的主题演讲。我做课程的方式是首先，我把所有东西都 100% 完全写下来。
All of the demos tested on all the operating systems, everything ready to rock. And then I start to record. And then in week one, I like record rock. And then I start to record. And then in week one, I like record a module and then I give it to my editor. And then week two, I record a module and I get the first one back from my editor and I review it. And then I send it to a tech reviewer and blah, blah. And so there's like a pipeline, right? And so we get to the conference and I had just finished recording everything, but there were like four modules in the pipeline. So after the conference, I got everything reviewed, edited and slammed over, but Pluralsight was gonna be away for a week.
所有的演示都在所有操作系统上进行过测试，一切准备就绪。然后我开始录制。然后在第一周，我录制，然后我开始录制。然后在第一周，我录制一个模块，然后我把它交给我的编辑。然后在第二周，我录制一个模块，我从我的编辑那里拿回第一个模块并复查。然后我把它发给技术审稿人，等等，等等。所以有一个流水线，对吧？所以我们到了会议现场，我刚刚完成所有东西的录制，但流水线里还有大约四个模块。所以在会议结束后，我把所有东西都审核、编辑并赶了出来，但 Pluralsight 要离开一周。
So I'm like, I'm gonna miss it. They're gonna be away from like August 4th to 9th or something. But no, on that Friday, they took it live. So whatever the last Friday in July was, the course went live. And it's a complete rewrite. It's taken me months of the C++ Fundamentals course.
所以我想，我会错过它的。他们将从 8 月 4 日到 9 日左右离开。但没有，在那周五，他们让它上线了。所以无论七月的最后一个星期五是什么时候，这门课程就上线了。这是一个完全的重写。C++ 基础课程花了我几个月的时间。
So this is like the entry point for people who know some programming languages, but don't know C++ and take them from zero to C++ programmer. And I've had this course there for a really long time, and it gets updated with new versions of C++. But also every time I update it, I change usually something very significant. So at one point, I keep moving pointers, for example, further and further into the course because I just don't think you need pointers.
所以这对于那些懂一些编程语言，但不懂 C++ 的人来说是一个切入点，带他们从零走到 C++ 程序员。我在那里开设这门课程已经很长时间了，并且会随着 C++ 的新版本进行更新。而且每次我更新它时，我通常都会改变非常重要的一些东西。所以在某个时候，例如，我不断地将指针在课程中推得越来越靠后，因为我只是觉得你不需要指针。
It's no big deal. Like, well, we can do polymorphism and stuff with references. We'll mention pointers eventually, but it's not as important as people used to think it was. I added a whole new section this time on error handling because it's a big deal. And there's not a lot of syntax in it because it's mostly strategy. It's like, well, you could return a bool, true or false, success or fail. Or you could return an optional. You could return some sort of an error object.
这没什么大不了的。比如，我们可以用引用来做多态性之类的事情。我们最终会提到指针，但它不像人们过去认为的那样重要。这次我关于错误处理添加了一个全新的部分，因为这是一个大问题。里面没有太多的语法，因为它主要是策略。就像，你可以返回一个布尔值（bool），成功或失败，true 或 false。或者你可以返回一个可选值（optional）。你可以返回某种错误对象。
You could have out params and we. We ended up talking about expected. There is... You can also throw an exception. Okay, well, exceptions happen, but we talk about expected first. And I would like to do std expected, but I can't because we're in C++20, but Cy has a nice one. So I say here's, you know, Cy's expected
你可以有输出参数，我们。我们最后讨论了 expected。有……你也可以抛出异常。好吧，异常会发生，但我们首先讨论 expected。我想要 std expected，但我不能，因为我们使用的是 C++20，但 Cy 有一个不错的。所以我说这里是，你知道，Cy 的 expected
and it's lovely. Here's how to use it. And then we talk about exceptions. Then we talk about RAII again, which has been talked about before, but how in the context of both exceptions and returning early, you know, getting that guaranteed cleanup is good for you. So there's not a ton of syntax other than the exception syntax, but it's a sort of a strategic module. That one's new this time around. And just everything I think should be in a C++ introduction, you know. And did you say that there was two, because I heard you mention at
而且它很可爱。这是如何使用它。然后我们讨论异常。然后我们再次讨论 RAII，这以前已经讨论过了，但在异常和提前返回的上下文中，你知道，获得那种保证的清理对你有好处。所以除了异常语法之外，没有太多的语法，但它是一种战略模块。这次这个是新的。还有我认为应该包含在 C++ 介绍中的所有内容，你知道。你是不是说有两个，因为我听到你提到
one point what's new in C++20 and then C++20 in depth or something? Was there two courses? So in C++20 fundamentals is, let me see how many hours it is, seven and a half hours of material. So that's a lot, especially on Pluralsight. You know, they have some one hour courses. And for a while there, they had a brief fling with, we're not going to have long courses. Everything's going to be short. And then people can just take three courses, but they kind of changed their minds back. And I think that's good for this. But earlier this year, I did a what's new in C++20, which is like, you already know about C++, the language, you already work in it, but you just want to see what's new in C++ 20, which is like you already know about C++, the language,
有一次提到 C++20 的新特性，然后是深入浅出 C++20 之类的？有两门课程吗？所以 C++20 基础是，让我看看有多少小时，七个半小时的材料。所以这很多，特别是在 Pluralsight 上。你知道，他们有一些一小时的课程。有一段时间，他们对“我们不会有长课程。一切都要短。然后人们可以只选修三门课程”浅尝辄止，但他们后来改变了主意。我认为这对这个很好。但今年早些时候，我做了一个 C++20 的新特性，就像是，你已经了解 C++，这门语言，你已经在其中工作了，但你只是想看看 C++ 20 中的新特性，就像你已经了解 C++，这门语言，
you already work in it, but you just want to see what's been added. So I talk briefly about modules and concepts and, you know, std format and spaceship and just things that got added in 20 that I think people should know about. And very quick demos just to show why you care. The time zone stuff in chronono, that kind of thing. That might slip by you otherwise. But you're not going to learn C++ from a course like that. So the fundamentals course is for the people who want to learn it. But I also have a learn to program in C++ course,
你已经在其中工作了，但你只是想看看添加了什么。所以我简要谈到了模块和概念，（你知道的）std format 和太空船操作符（spaceship），以及 20 中添加的我认为人们应该知道的事情。以及非常快速的演示，只是为了展示你为什么关心它。chrono 中的时区相关内容，诸如此类。否则这些可能会被你漏掉。但你不会从这样的课程中学习 C++。所以基础课程是给那些想要学习它的人准备的。但我还有一门“学习用 C++ 编程”的课程，
which is for people who have never programmed in anything and are willing to learn C++ as their first programming language. And I know a lot of people tell me that's impossible, but like a lot of people have taken this course and been very happy. They don't want to have to learn something else first as like an admission price or table stakes or whatever, and then go learn the language they really want to work in. So I teach them C++ from the point of view of someone who, like sometimes you want the computer to do the same thing for you over and over again. We call this a loop and then explain the various loops we have in C++.
这适用于从未用任何语言编程过、并愿意将 C++ 作为他们的第一门编程语言来学习的人。我知道很多人告诉我这是不可能的，但很多人都上了这门课程并且非常高兴。他们不想为了作为入场券或基本要求什么的，首先不得不去学习其他东西，然后再去学习他们真正想用的语言。所以我从一个人的角度教他们 C++，比如有时你希望计算机一遍又一遍地为你做同样的事情。我们称之为循环，然后解释我们在 C++ 中拥有的各种循环。
And that works. It can be done and I think it's worth doing if you, for whatever reason, want to learn C++ first. Go ahead. You don't have to learn something else. That is actually one of the, I'd say, strongest arguments. Not that I agree in general that C++ should be the first language folks learn or is the best language as a first language. But if you're going to make that argument, one of the strongest arguments I've heard is that if you learn C++, C++ is a language that you can do anything you want, usually like 10 different ways. Which means it's a superset of like almost everything in every other language.
这行得通。这是可以做到的，而且如果你出于某种原因想首先学习 C++，我认为这是值得做的。去吧。你不必去学习别的。这实际上是，我要说，最强有力的论据之一。并不是说我总体上同意 C++ 应该是人们学习的第一门语言，或者作为第一门语言是最好的语言。但如果你要提出这个论据，我听过的最强有力的论据之一是，如果你学习 C++，C++ 是一门你可以用通常像 10 种不同的方式做你想做的任何事情的语言。这意味着它是几乎所有其他语言中几乎所有内容的超集。
Like it's to a to like asterisk. That's not completely true. There obviously are things you can do, I'm sure, in Haskell or pure functional languages that you're not going to be able to identically replicate. But for, you know, in general, if you learn everything about C++, you're not going to be too surprised when you go to other languages. You'll be like, oh, this is just this, you know, the maybe from Haskell is like the optional and this thing from Java
就像，用星号表示。这并非完全正确。显然有些事情，我确信，你可以在 Haskell 或纯函数式语言中做到，而你无法以相同的方式复制它们。但对于，你知道，总的来说，如果你了解关于 C++ 的一切，当你转向其他语言时，你不会感到太惊讶。你会想，哦，这只是这个，你知道，Haskell 中的 maybe 就像 optional，以及来自 Java 的这个东西
or this thing for Go or this thing in Swift. It's all going to be roughly equivalent to at least something in C++ because C++ basically has everything. Has absolutely everything, even things people really don't use anymore, but it's still in there.
或者来自 Go 的这个东西，或者 Swift 中的这个东西。所有这些都将大致相当于 C++ 中的至少某些东西，因为 C++ 基本上拥有一切。绝对拥有一切，甚至人们真正不再使用的东西，但它仍然在里面。
But, you know, imagine if you chose some language that doesn't have lambdas. And then when you moved to a language that did have lambdas, you'd have to learn the concept of lambdas. Whereas if you go learn C++ first, then you go to a language that doesn't have it, you're like, well, okay, I can figure out a workaround where I can get that ability that I want. So, but the key, the key to teaching a course like that is, you know, i'm not teaching function pointers i'm not teaching um c style arrays and pointer arithmetic to figure out where in the array you want to address like no it's 100 c++ and standard library and you know very expressive and very accessible and no well you have to be so smart to understand this most people
但是，你知道，想象一下如果你选择了一种没有 lambda 表达式的语言。然后当你转向一种确实有 lambda 表达式的语言时，你必须学习 lambda 的概念。而如果你先学习 C++，然后你去了一门没有它的语言，你会想，好吧，我可以想出一个变通办法，让我能够获得我想要的那种能力。所以，但教授这样一门课程的关键是，你知道，我没有教函数指针，我没有教 C 风格的数组和指针算术来弄清楚你想在数组的哪个地址寻址——不，它是 100% 的 C++ 和标准库，（你知道的）非常富有表现力且非常易懂，而且没有“哦，你必须非常聪明才能理解这一点，大多数人
are not wizardy enough to understand this. Most people are not wizardy enough to understand this, but I'm going to quickly review it with you. None of that. Yeah, that sounds awesome. We'll definitely leave links to both of those and everything. I mean, well, I'll probably just copy and paste the show notes from each of these three slices and they'll be the same. So in case you heard something two episodes ago and you're like, oh yeah, I wanted to see that. It'll be in the show notes for each of these. And we haven't done this historically, but I have actually made a mental note of trying to do this at the end of guest episodes. But then I just always forget because we never do it regularly is asking if
没有足够的魔法来理解这一点。大多数人没有足够的魔法来理解这一点，但我会和你一起快速复习一下。”没有那些。是的，听起来棒极了。我们肯定会留下这两者以及所有内容的链接。我的意思是，好吧，我可能会复制并粘贴这三个片段中的每一个的节目笔记，它们将是相同的。所以在你听到两个节目之前的东西，然后你想，哦，是的，我想看那个。它将出现在其中每一个的节目笔记中。我们历来没有这样做，但我实际上记下了在嘉宾剧集结束时尝试这样做的心理笔记。但随后我总是忘记，因为我们从来没有定期这样做，那就是询问
there's anything in general that you want to either either mention or talk or or plug or uh this is coming up um because yeah i think you know we have a platform where the platform is growing according to bryce we have bryce well uh for people who are in europe i have fans i don't know about you bryce's hair has fans yeah i am going to be in Norway in about two weeks. Oh, wow. At NDC. Does anyone know how to say the name of the town that NDC Tech Town is in? I wouldn't advise any of us trying it.
是否有任何一般性的东西你想提及或谈论，或者宣传，或者呃，这个即将到来，因为是的，我认为，你知道，我们有一个平台，根据布莱斯的说法，这个平台正在增长，我们有布莱斯，呃，对于在欧洲的人，我有粉丝，我不知道你怎么样，布莱斯的头发有粉丝是的，我大约两周后将在挪威。哦，哇。在 NDC。有人知道 NDC Tech Town 所在的城镇名字怎么发音吗？我不建议我们任何人尝试它。
Wait. Yeah. Is it? I'm going to take a risk. God. Wait. He's going to be banned from Norway next. No, this is going to be a city that's not even in Norway.
等等。是的。是吗？我要冒个险。天哪。等等。他接下来会被禁止入境挪威。不，这将是一个甚至不在挪威的城市。
But I thought for sure Oslo. Is Oslolo is no no that's where you fly to but it's in it's spelled kongsberg but there's two dots on the o so i don't think you say it might be like kongsberg or something like that we know we know the name of the town connor we're not guessing where other towns in norway we just want to know how to pronounce it i was i was concerned that i didn't i didn't have oslo in the right country and it wasn't in norway and that's why i was like well it clearly can't be oslo because we all know how to pronounce oslo well no because i know that uh okay basically i don't i'm terrible at geography um but no i don't know how to pronounce coburg it sounds like something like that and that's what so that's not an NDC is it that's a different conference
但我原以为肯定是奥斯陆。是奧斯洛罗吗？不，那是你飞往的地方，但它的拼写是孔斯贝格（Kongsberg），但 o 上有两个点，所以我不认为你那样说，它可能是孔斯贝格（Kongsberg）之类的。我们知道那个城镇的名字，康纳，我们不是在猜挪威的其他城镇，我们只是想知道怎么发音。我当时担心我没有把奥斯陆放在正确的国家，它不在挪威，这就是为什么我觉得“这显然不可能是奥斯陆，因为我们都知道奥斯陆怎么发音”。好吧，不，因为我知道呃，基本上我，我的地理太糟糕了，但——不，我不知道柯堡（Coburg）怎么发音。听起来像是那种名字，所以那不是 NDC，对吧？那是另一个会议。
NDC Tech Town which has got a very C++ focus there's a lot of NDC action in various places but Tech Town has got the kind of C++ so this is two weeks so when does that because maybe so that's going to be 29 so what
NDC Tech Town，它非常专注于 C++。在各个地方有很多 NDC 活动，但 Tech Town 有那种 C++ 所以这是两周后，那么这在什么时候，因为也许所以这将是 29 号，所以
we'll actually do this will be a little bit confusing for the listener because this will be the third episode of three the first of which will be airing on the 26th so you're hearing this outro from kate which is at the tail end of three different conversations but just so folks know that uh that's happening and i'm sure you're really gonna edit it like that? Bryce, literally our last two episodes, I said, I'm going to cut it off. Boom, right here. And then you were like, please don't do that.
我们实际上将这样做：这对听众来说会有点困惑，因为这将是三集中的第三集，其中第一集将于 26 日播出。所以你听到的是来自凯特的这段收尾，它位于三个不同对话的末尾，但只是为了让大家知道那正在发生，而且我确信你真的会那样剪辑吗？布莱斯，字面意思上我们的最后两集，我说，我要把它切掉。轰，就在这里。然后你说，请不要那样做。
That'll be bad. And then I made that the intro to episode 89 or whatever it was. I guess this is what I get for not exerting any editorial control or even listening to the episodes of this podcast. That's right. Bryce always says, I'm not going to let you put that in or, you know the episodes of this podcast that's right always says i'm not gonna let you put that in or you know we're not doing that but that never has any impact because i'm the one that does all this because you're the one who's editing yeah yeah but i just but bryce's voice up at 10x and then i am the executive producer and i believe i am the headliner right i think every once in a while i should like turn Bryce's mic down and then like in your narrator voice, you can go.
那会很糟糕。然后我把它作为第 89 集的开场白，或者不管那是第几集。我想这就是我不行使任何编辑控制权甚至不听这个播客的剧集的代价。没错。布莱斯总是说，我不会让你把那个放进去，或者，你知道这个播客的剧集，没错，总是说我不会让你把那个放进去，或者你知道我们不那样做，但这从来没有任何影响，因为我是做所有这些的人，因为你是那个在编辑的人，是的，是的，但我只是把布莱斯的麦克风开到 10 倍，然后我是执行制片人，我相信我是主角，对吧？我想每隔一段时间我应该把布莱斯的麦克风调小，然后像你的旁白声音一样，你可以继续。
He went on about bagels for some time and turn it back up. Yeah. Like I said, sometimes he'll talk about his furniture and I'm like, this is the fifth time in 10 episodes that the listener is hearing about his walnut or whatever. I do. Yeah, I do. Bryce. about his walnut or whatever i do yeah i do bryce listener if you remember hearing me 10xing bryce's voice please leave a comment on twitter to uh and at bryce so that he knows so that he's aware my i think my girlfriend would love to be able to do that because she frequently complains that i
他喋喋不休地谈论贝果好一会儿，然后把它调回来。是的。就像我说的，有时他会谈论他的家具，我想，这是听众在 10 集里第五次听到关于他的胡桃木或诸如此类的事情。我是。是的，我是。布莱斯。关于他的胡桃木或诸如此类的东西。我是。是的，我是。布莱斯。听众朋友们，如果你还记得听到我把布莱斯的音量放大 10 倍，请在 Twitter 上发表评论来呃并 @ 布莱斯，以便他知道，以便他意识到我的女友会很乐意能够做到这一点，因为她经常抱怨我
just repeat all my stories she's like you told me this like you do i tell you that on this pot i'm like bryce they our listener knows they've heard it four times and you're like i don't care it's our podcast and the listener is going to be entertained but like but like with her i genuinely am like i've never told you this before and she's like you've told me this three times so you're old before your time that's like that's yeah she she's like i can't imagine what you're going to be like when you're old you're just gonna have one story no when you're old in addition to only having one story you start your story like this now i think it was in 1993 or maybe it was 94 no i'm pretty sure it was 93 no how old was jennifer then and like you had like a 20 minute pre-conversation to establish what year the story happened in before you can actually tell the story.
总是重复我所有的故事。她说，你跟我说过这个，就像你一样。我是在这个播客里对你说的吗？我说，布莱斯，我们的听众知道，他们已经听过四遍了。而你说，我不在乎，这是我们的播客，听众会觉得很有趣。但就像，但对她而言，我发自内心地说“我以前从未对你说过这个”，而她说“你已经跟我说过三次了”。所以你未老先衰了。那就是，是的，她说，我无法想象你老了会是什么样子，你只会有一个故事。不，当你老了，除了只有一个故事之外，你开始你的故事是这样的：现在，我想那是在 1993 年，或者也许是 94 年，不，我很确定那是 93 年，不，詹妮弗那时多大？就像你有长达 20 分钟的对话前奏，来确定故事发生在哪一年，然后才能真正开始讲故事。
That's the most frustrating thing. Yes. Yeah. My grandparents are 88 and 92 and you ask them when something happened and they'll like, they'll give you an estimate that's like, with like, they won't give you a year. They'll give you like a rough decade. Like that was sometime in the 60s. I don't know when. And they'll tell you what, what car they were driving or where they lived or something.
这是最让人沮丧的事情。是的。是的。我的祖父母 88 岁和 92 岁，你问他们某事是什么时候发生的，他们会给你一个估计，比如，带有一个，他们不会给你一个具体的年份。他们会给你一个粗略的十年。比如那是 60 年代某时。我不知道是什么时候。他们会告诉你当时他们开什么车，或者他们住在哪里之类的。
And that's supposed to figure it out. But then they get into an argument about when they sold that car. Yeah. Right. What else should I plug? We didn't even talk about carbon. I was about to ask. Oh, yeah.
然后你应该自己把它琢磨出来。但随后他们会为他们是什么时候卖掉那辆车而争论不休。是的。对。我还应该宣传什么？我们甚至没有谈论碳（Carbon）。我正要问。哦，是的。
Did we talk about carbon and I forgot about that? No. How could you? We just had the conversation, Bryce. Holy. You need to get your memory checked, my guy. Look, I'm a little distracted. I'm babysitting the dog.
我们谈论过碳，而我忘了这回事吗？没有。你怎么能忘？我们刚刚才聊过，布莱斯。天哪。老兄，你需要去检查一下记忆力了。听着，我有点分心。我在照看这只狗。
I'm trying to get the dog from eating whatever this thing used to be. I think it used to be a ball, but now it's like half a ball. Well, I mean, we had this till 730. I'm not sure when your hard stop is. We can talk a little longer. It's not dark out yet. Let's do it. All right, listener.
我正试图阻止这只狗吃这东西以前是什么。我觉得它以前是个球，但现在它像半个球。好吧，我的意思是，我们有这个直到 7:30。我不确定你的硬性截止时间是什么时候。我们可以多聊一会儿。天还没黑呢。我们开始吧。好吧，听众朋友们。
I want to get more details on where Kate is right now, because it seems to be like a rustic cabin of some sort. It is literally a log cabin. There's a brand of cabins called Pan Abode. And it is a cedar logs. And they built this in like the 60s this land was in the same family from the 30s until last year oh wow so the dog just went into i'm sorry this is the worst i'm gonna like i'm gonna get a new co-host price you've gone so available i'm just saying kate's in the middle of telling us an epic story
我想了解更多关于凯特现在在哪里的细节，因为这似乎是一个某种质朴的小木屋。它字面意思上就是一个原木小屋。有一个品牌的木屋叫 Pan Abode。它是雪松原木。他们在 60 年代左右建造了这个，这片土地从 30 年代到去年一直属于同一个家族。哦，哇。所以狗刚刚进去了，我很抱歉，这是最糟糕的，我打算像，我要换一个新的联合主持人，布莱斯，你变得太有空了，我只是说，凯特正在讲一个史诗般的故事
seven decades eight decades nine decades and bryce's response listen folks i've got a dog here and i've got something to tell you i tell you you're on thin ice bryce i'm gonna i'm gonna replace you and record an episode you won't even know about it and you'll be like whoa what's this why is everyone talking i'm sorry but the dog comes over with a toy that, like, I'm like, that doesn't look like one of the toys that she's been given yet. She must have retrieved it from out of my backpack, which I could have sworn was zipped. Dogs are smarter than you think. Wait till you get a kid.
七十年，八十年，九十年，而布莱斯的反应是：听着，各位，我这里有一只狗，我有些话要告诉你。我告诉你，你现在如履薄冰，布莱斯。我要，我要取代你，录制一个你甚至都不会知道的节目，然后你会想，哇，这是什么？为什么每个人都在说话？我很抱歉，但这只狗带过来一个玩具，就像，我想，这看起来不像给过她的玩具之一。她一定是把它从我的背包里找出来了，我本可以发誓拉链是拉上的。狗比你想象的要聪明。等你有了孩子就知道了。
You'll be sorry. Yeah, I'm sure I will be. Anyways, we were talking about Log Cabin. Log Cabin, 1930s till 2021. And so this is an acquisition or acquisition is the correct word? I don't know why they put it on the market last year, but they did. And we bought it. And we didn't get to spend a ton of time here last summer because my daughter-in-law was having a very tough pregnancy and she needed
你会后悔的。是的，我确信我会的。不管怎样，我们刚才在谈论原木小屋。原木小屋，20 世纪 30 年代到 2021 年。所以这是一个收购，或者说收购是正确的词吗？我不知道为什么他们在去年把它放到市场上，但他们确实这么做了。我们买下了它。去年夏天我们没能在这里花很多时间，因为我儿媳的孕期非常艰难，她需要
a lot of support and she ended up in the hospital and blah blah saying a lot of free time but we're coming here a lot more this summer and uh it is it is just a cabin on the lake and it's a great place to disconnect and it's it seems like you got awesome like that's my number one concern absolutely love nature absolutely love hiking all that stuff swimming etc uh but like my blood my second blood is uh is the internet and without like good internet i start to um suffocate but it seems like you got fantastic internet there i've got we've got pretty good internet we've got pretty good internet it's not um uh it's not enormous bandwidth like you you know you don't want to watch tv 24 hours a day but that's not enormous bandwidth. You don't want to watch TV 24 hours a day, but that's not why you're here, right?
很多支持，最后她进了医院，诸如此类，说有很多空闲时间，但今年夏天我们来这里更多了呃，它只是湖边的一个小屋，是断开连接的好地方，而且看起来你得到了很棒的就像这是我最关心的绝对热爱大自然，绝对热爱徒步旅行，所有这些东西，游泳等等，呃，但我的第二血液是互联网，如果没有像样的互联网，我开始呃窒息，但看起来你在那里有极好的互联网？我们有，我们有相当不错的互联网。我们有相当不错的互联网。它不是呃，它不是那种巨大的带宽，就像你，你知道，你不想一天 24 小时看电视，但这并不是巨大的带宽。你不想一天 24 小时看电视，但这不是你来这里的目的，对吧？
When you need it, a little spurt, you've got good bandwidth, and then you turn it off or stop using it. We chose our house based on having access to the Internet 30 years ago. Did you? Wow. In those days, you could get a list of all the sites on the internet that you could dial up to. And we chose, like, we have to be a free call to this place and that place because we can dial up and get internet. And before we moved, I arranged with Trent University, which is in Peterborough, to have a dial-up account that I could dial into so that I could telnet back to U of T to finish my work. Yeah, that totally makes sense.
当你需要它时，来点小爆发，你拥有良好的带宽，然后你把它关掉或停止使用它。我们 30 年代根据是否有机会接入互联网来选择我们的房子。是吗？哇。在那些日子里，你可以获得一份互联网上所有你可以拨号连接的网站的清单。我们选择，就像，我们必须是打到这个地方和那个地方的免费电话，因为我们可以拨号并获得互联网。在我搬家之前，我与位于彼得伯勒的特伦特大学（Trent University）安排了一个拨号账户，我可以拨号进去，以便我可以 telnet 回多伦多大学完成我的工作。是的，这完全说得通。
I mean, I, when I think about where I permanently want to live, like, I don't know if it's number one, but like number four is like, do they have like fiber optic, like high speed internet here? Cause like, you know, you can get by with less today. Uh, but like going forward, you're going to need, um, at least if you're going to be working remotely and spending all your days on zoom calls etc and uh nvidia is you know one of the companies inventing inventing uh omniverse etc and it's going to require a certain amount of bandwidth and that uh what you need is excellent bandwidth and then something to make you not care that you have bandwidth and walk away from it and leave your phone behind which a lake a lake does well uh it does well for that it really
我的意思是，我，当我考虑我永远想住在哪里时，就像，我不知道这是否是第一位，但就像第四位是，这里有光纤宽带、高速互联网吗？因为，你知道，今天你可以用更少的带宽应付过去。呃，但展望未来，你需要呃，至少如果你要远程工作并把所有的日子都花在 Zoom 会议上等等，而且英伟达（Nvidia）是发明发明全宇宙（Omniverse）等技术的公司之一，它将需要一定数量的带宽，而那，你需要的是出色的带宽，然后是某种能让你不在乎拥有带宽并走开、把手机抛在脑后的东西，湖泊，一个湖泊做得很好呃它在这方面做得很好，真的
does a lake with our canoe and this is a canoeing area it's an unofficial crown land called the frost center canoe area and it is uh it's got campsites and portages and all of that. And our cottage is actually in that canoe area. Yeah, I'll have to make a point of being able to make it out to the CPP North post-retreat afterwards. Post-conference retreat. I think that's a new tradition for sure. Yeah. Yeah. And hopefully we won't be dealing with the carbon announcement next year.
很好。一个带有独木舟的湖泊，这是一个独木舟区。它是一个非官方的皇冠土地（Crown land），叫做弗罗斯特中心独木舟区（Frost Center canoe area），它呃，它有营地和搬运路线以及所有这些。我们的别墅实际上就在那个独木舟区里。是的，我得找个机会确保能够赶上之后的 CPP North 会后静修。会议后静修。我认为这绝对是一个新传统。是的。是的。希望我们明年不会处理碳宣布的事。
Although someone said Google has promised to announce two programming languages next year so that's fair yeah carbon plus plus and something else um speaking of which yeah thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
虽然有人说谷歌承诺明年宣布两种编程语言，所以这很公平，是的，Carbon plus plus 和其他什么顺便说一句，是的，谢谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。